[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى في
الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث وتتفاعل
اخرى والبدايه من ام درمان حيث نتابع هذه
الصور مع انتهاء وقف اطلاق النار المتفق
عليه بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني والغموض الذي يكتنف المرحله
المقبله
من كوسوفو تاتيكم هذه الصور تحديدا
العاصمه برشتينا هذه الصور المباشره مع
استمرار التوتر في شمال الاقليم وتواصل
الاضطرابات
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
في هجوم غير مسبوق منذ 33 عاما عند الحدود
المصريه الاسرائيليه شرطي مصري يقتل ثلاثه
جنود اسرائيليين ويصيب طابقا القاهره تقول
انهم سقطتوا خلال مطارده عنصر امن مصري
لمهربي مخدرات عند معبر العوجه وتل ابيب
تقول ان الشرطي لم يتسلل بل دخل من معبر
طوارئ فتعهد بان يصل التحقيق الى منتهى
ووزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي يبلغ نظيره
المصري ان التعاون في التحقيق له اهميه
بالنسبه للعلاقه بين البلد
مع زياده وتيره الهجمات على الروسيه حاكم
المقاطعه يعلن وقف حركه المواصلات بسبب
خطوره الوضع ورئيس شركه فاجنر يقول ان
المقاطعه تشهد فوضى قد تحتم تدخل قواته
وموسكت تؤكد الانفتاح على طرق اخرى لحل
الصراع لكنها ترى فرنسا طرفا غير محايد
لاستضافه قمه عالميه لتعديل شروط التسويه
الاخرى
رئيس وزراء يتهم ميليشيات مرتبطه
بتاجيج الاضطرابات في الشمال ويقول في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان الغرب يسترد صربيا
لابعادها عن روسيا وان بلاده يجب الا تدفع
الثمن ذلك والرئيس الصربي يقول انه ليس من
مصلحه بلاده مواجهه النيتو وانها لا تريد
الا مساعده الاغلبيه الصربيه في شمال
كوسوفي
[موسيقى]
هدنه الايام الخمسه في السودان تنتهي دون
افق لتجديدها على وقع غارات للجيش
السوداني على مواقع للدعم السريع في مناطق
الخرطوم وتوقف العمل في مستشفى سوبا بسبب
مواجهات في غرب العاصمه وجنوبها في
دارفورد نقابه الاطباء تطلق نداء استغاثه
بالفعل الاشتباكات وتؤكد مغادره منظمات
انسانيه للمنطقه
الرئيس التركي يعلن تشكيله الحكومه
الجديده تعيين جوده يلمز نائبا للرئيس
وهكان فيدان وزيرا للخارجيه اردوغان يدعو
لدى ادائه اليمين الدستوريه الى احترام
الاراده التي افرزتها الانتخابات ويقول ان
بلاده ستواصل ممارسه دور فعال في المنطقه
والعالم
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا ما كشفه برنامج المسافه
صفر في تحقيقه الميداني الجديد الهند من
اشعل الفتيل وذلك على وجود حملات في عده
ولايات هنديه لهدم ممتلكات المسلمين من
منازل وشركات وكيف ان منظمه هندوسيه
متطرفه هي من يقف وراء ارتفاع جرائم
الكراهيه في جميع انحاء الهند لاستطلاعي
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم
السؤال التالي برايكم ما خلفيات
الانتهاكات التي تحصل لمسلمي الهند التي
كشف عنها المسافه صفر
60% قالوا انها خلفيات طائفيه 30 قالوا
انها خلفيات عرقيه بينما اعتبرها عشره في
المئه خلفيات سياسيه
طبعا هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويح عبر
مسح الرمز كيو ار الذي يظهر الان على
الشاشه
اللقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودويا
[موسيقى]
اذا في هجوم غير مسبوق منذ ثلاثه وثلاثين
عاما عند الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه اعلن
الجيش الاسرائيلي ان الثلاثه من جنوده
قتلوا اليوم برصاص شرطي مصري وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان الجنديين قتل بعد مشاركتهما
في عمليه احباط محاوله لتهريب كميات كبيره
من المخدرات بينما اوضح المتحدث العسكري
المصري ان الجنود الاسرائيليين قتلوا خلال
مطارده عنصر امن مصري لمهربى مخدرات عند
معبر العوجه وصف رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليه
الحادثه بالدميه واكد على مواصله التحقيق
حتى النهايه
ثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين قتلوا قنصا وفي
اشتباك مسلح وفقا لروايه الجيش الاسرائيلي
المكان هنا في الجانب الاسرائيلي عند معبر
العوجه للبضائع التجاريه عند الحدود بين
مصر واسرائيل تذكر روايه الجيش الاسرائيلي
ان جنديين قتل قنصا عند الفجر ثم قتل ثالث
واصيب ضابط في اشتباك مسلح مع منفذ عمليه
القنص عند الظهر
تشير الروايه الاسرائيليه ايضا الى ان
منفذ الهجوم الشرطي المصري وصفته بالمخرب
وان تحقيقا ومحادثات اجراها الجيش
الاسرائيلي مع الجيش المصري
في التفاصيل ايضا ذكرت مصادر للجزيره ان
الجيش الاسرائيلي عثر على الجنديين اللذين
قتل فجرا بعد ساعات من مقتلهما اما روايه
الجيش المصري فبدت مختلفه فقد تحدثت عن
مطارده واطلاق نار بين احد عناصر الامن
ومهربي مخدرات اسفرت عن مقتل عنصر الامن
وثلاثه جنود اسرائيليين واصابه اثنين
الجيشان المصري والاسرائيلي قال كل على
حده انه ما يجريان عمليات بحث وتمشيط
وتفتيش في المنطقه كما اغلقت الشرطه
الاسرائيليه كل الطرق والمحاور التي تؤدي
الى الحدود مع مصر
[موسيقى]
وقال متحدث عسكري مصري الفريق اول محمد
زكي وزير الدفاع والانتاج الحربي اجرى
اتصالا هاتفيا بناظره الاسرائيلي لبحث
ملابسات حادث الحدود والتنسيق لمنع تكرار
مثلي تلك الحوادث
اما هيئه البث الاسرائيليه فقالت من
جانبها نوازير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
تحدث مع نظيره المصري واوضح له ان العلاقه
بين الطرفين مهمه للغايه وبحسب الهيئه فقد
اكد جراند لنظيره المصري ان تعاون في
التحقيق في الهجوم الخطير له اهميه كبيره
بالنسبه للعلاقه بين الدولتين
من واشنطن الدكتور خليل العناني استاذ
العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات الدوليه اهلا
بك دكتور خليل اذا هناك اختلاف في
الروايات الاسرائيليه والمصريه بشان ما
وقع اليوم ماذا نقرا في هذا الاختلاف اولا
وما دلالته برايك
انا اعتقد الاختلاف في يعود بشكل او باخر
الى عده عوامل العام الاول متعلق بعدم
اكتمال الصوره حتى هذه اللحظه هناك عالم
يبدو عنصر مفاجاه فجاه الطرفين المصري
والاسرائيلي خاصه هناك حاله هدوء وسكون
لحد بعيد عن الحدود المصريه الاسرائيليه
على الاقل منذ 30 عاما وبالتالي لم يكن
الامر متوقعا الامر الثاني متعلق بتدعيات
الحادث على البلدين من جانب المصري يخشى
بشكل او باخر ان تؤدي هذه الحادثه الى
وجود ازمه الدبلوماسيه او سياسيه مع
اسرائيل وبالتالي التقليل حجم التعاون
العسكري بين الطرفين الطرف الاسرائيلي في
النهايه يريد ان يعرف اصل الموضوع وان
يتاكد ان هذا الموضوع موضوع فردي بالاساس
ولا يعبر عن وجود توجه ما تيار مداخل
الجيش المصري خاصه فيما يتعلق بالحدود
المصريه الاسرائيليه التي تعتبر بشكل او
باخر حدود لا تتمتع بوجود عسكري كثيف من
الطرف المصري كما نعلم جميعا حسب اتفاقيه
معادله السلامه لتوقعت اخر السبعينات
وبالتالي هناك حاله مفاجاه وقد تكون حاله
صدمه في الجانب الاسرائيلي يعتبر او كان
يعتبر الحدود المصريه باعتبارها حدودا
ساكنه من الحد البعيده وبالتالي اختلاف
الروايتين يعكس اختلاف تقييم الطرفين لهذه
المساله والتخوف متدعيتها مستقبلا على
المستقبل العلاقات بين الطرفين ولكن يعني
كان هناك حرص من الطرفين على القول انه لن
يؤثر على العلاقات مع التاكيد على استمرار
التحقيقات ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه على
خلفيه ما وقع اليوم من ترتيبات امنيه
اجراءات ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه
انا اعتقد هذه الواقعه قد تؤدي الى دفع
المزيد من التعامل الطرفين نعلم جميعا
خاصه منذ الذي حدث في مصر في عام 2013
والصعود الطيارات المتطرفه هناك خاصه
تنظيم الدوله هناك التعاون امني اسرائيلي
مصري غير مسبوق على سبيل المثال مثلا ذكرت
تايمز قبل حوالي سته عمدام انه في عام
2017 قامت اسرائيل على الاقل بحوالي 100
ضربه جويه داخل الاراضي المصريه في مفترضه
على تنظيم الدوله وهذا يعتبر رقم كبير جدا
هناك حاله تنسيق امن مرتفع للغايه اعترف
بها الرئيس الحالي عبد الفتاح السيسي في
لقائه مع احد القنوات الامريكيه عندما
تحدث عن وجود تنسيق العدد المستويات مع
اسرائيل وبالتالي لا توقع هناك تاثير سلبي
بالعكس تاثير ايجابي قد ادفع الطرفين او
يدفع الطرفان الى تعزيز وجودهم العسكري
هناك قد نرى تعديل ما لاتفاقيه او للملحق
الخاص بتفاقيه السلام الى الطرفين بالدفع
بوجود قوات عسكريه مصريه ثقلت التسليح حتى
دي لحظه هناك فقط افراد المصريه تسليح
خفيف الى حد بعده بالتالي من الصعب مواجهه
اي تطرف او اي جامعات هناك في هذه المنطقه
بالتلات صور انه هذه العمليه ما لم يتم ان
تتبع بعمليات اخرى في المستقبل نتحدث عن
عمليه واحده فقط قد يتم للامه الموضوع
وبالتالي الدفع باتفاق بين الطرفين لتاكيد
الحدود بينهما حتى العمليه مره اخرى في
المستقبل القريب اشكرك الدكتور خليل
العناني استاذه العلوم السياسيه والعلاقات
الدوليه ينضم الان الينا من عمان اللواء
فايز الدويري الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي
اذا
مره اخرى قراءه في البيانين المختلفين من
الجانب الاسرائيلي والجانب المصري عسكريا
تتباين هذه القراءه كيف
اولا الجانب المصري الجانب المصري تقريبا
يحاول ان يقول ان العمل الذي جرى او ما
حصل فجر هذا اليوم ليس اكثر من قرار خاطئ
اتخذه
احد افراد الشرطه
لمعالجه خطر دائم هم تم ربط العمليه
بمهربين مخدرات
ورجل الامن المصري تعامل معهم وكان قراره
باجتياز من باب الطوارئ اجتاز المدخل
وتابع عمله وبالتالي حدث ما حدث وجرى
اطلاق نار وتم قتل المجند والمجند ومن ثم
حدث اشتباك اخر فهو ليس اكثر من تصرف شخصي
بناء على معطيات هكذا قرا المشهد فكان
الحكومه المصريه وضعت العمليه كلها في
اطار تفكير رجل امن بمعالجه موقف طارئ ليس
هناك توجه
لتنفيذ عمليه ليس هناك تفكير مدبر مسبق
لان سلمان خاطر لا يزال في الذاكره
المصريه والذاكره الاسرائيليه عندما قتل
سبعه منهم اربعه اطفال وكانت العمليه
تعتبر مدبره فالان يجب ابعاد شبح سلمان
خاطر عن دائره التفكير هكذا التوجه المصري
القراءه الاسرائيلي لا تؤكد ان العمل هو
عمل مدبر لماذا لانه روايته تقول ان من
قتل في اولا حادث تهريب المخدرات قبل عده
ساعات
الذي جرى ان من قتل في الفجر المجند
والمجنده في بعض وسائل الاعلام
الاسرائيليه قالوا بانهم لم يطلق النار
وبالتالي كانت عمليه قوس لهم دون ان
يعلموا بما جرى وثم لماذا اختبا عده ساعات
ولماذا اشتبك مره اخرى وقتل ثالثا وجرح
شخصين ثم تم تحيده فكان الجانب الاسرائيلي
يقول ان سلمان خاطر رقم اثنين
ظهر على ظهر على المسرح بينما الجانب
المصري انا اقرا انه يقول قرار خاطئ من
مجند بسيط لا يملك الاجراك الاستراتيجي كل
طرف روايه الطرف الاخر ما الذي سنشهده
خلال الايام القادمه من وجهه نظرك خصوصا
كما ذكر الدكتور خليل هذه جبهه ساكنه يعني
في النهايه ما حدث
ليست بالضبط ما كانت اسرائيل مستعده له او
تحتاجه في هذا الوقت
بغض النظر التحقيق المشترك اقول واؤكد على
كلمه المشترك التحقيق المشترك سيبين
الحقائق لماذا الجدار
او الحاجز لانه في بعض الحالات جدار وحاجز
وفي بعض الحالات حاجز لوحده هو معزز
بالكاميرات وبالتالي بالعوده الى
التسجيلات سيتم بيان الحقائق من اين دخل
هل دخل من فتحه الطوارئ هل دخل من فتحه
التي استخدمها المهربين وبالتالي سيتم
اعاده رسم المشهد
ويتوصلوا الى حقيقه لانه الان اهم شيء
بالنسبه للاسرائيليين ان لا يكون من نفذ
العمليه يسمى يحمل توجها معينا وبالتالي
هو قام بعمليه من وجهه نظرية عمليه وطنيه
عمليه بطوليه بينما هم سيكون مرتاحين جدا
اذا البيان المصري اذا البيان المصري دقيق
ومهما كانت النتيجه سيكون هناك اجراءات
اهم هذه الاجراءات من وجهه نظري ان سيطلب
سيطلب من الجانب المصري الت دقيق الامن
الشامل لكل من يعمل في هذه المنطقه منطقه
جيم يجب ان يكون تدقيق امني شامل لخلفيه
كافه العاملين وبانهم لا يحملوا اي
التوجهات خاصه توجهات اسلاميه هذا ما
ستحسمه اذا الكاميرات كاميرات المراقبه
اشكرك لواء فايزه دويري الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي من عمان
[موسيقى]
رئيس شركه فاجنر يفكيني ان الوضع في
بلجورد يتسم بالفوضى التي قد تحتم تدخل
قواته كما تتعرض مقاطعه للاستهداف منذ
الشهر الاول للحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وزادت وتيره الهجمات
ونوعيتها في الاسابيع الماضيه تعتبر هذه
المقاطعه خط امداد رئيس للقوات الروسيه
الموجوده داخل اوكرانيا واهميه للجيش
الروسي وتفاصيل الوضع فيها نتابع في هذا
التقرير
مقاطعه بالجراد الروسيه تحت مرمى النيران
الاوكرانيه ليس الامر جديدا فاستهداف
المنطقه الروسيه المحاذيه للحدود الشماليه
الاوكرانيه بدا منذ الشهر الاول للحرب لكن
الهجمات تعظمت كمن ونوعا
تقع جنوب غرب روسيا لها حدود مع اوكرانيا
طولها 450 كيلومترا تقريبا تحاذي مقاطعات
ولا تزيد المسافه بين وسط برجراد ووسط خار
كيد على خمسين كيلومترا تحمل بالجراد
اهميه استراتيجيه لروسيا تشكل المقاطعه خط
امداد
وتحرك رئيسي للقوات الروسيه وشكلت بوابه
لعبور الجنود الروسي الى خاركاف وشمال
اوكرانيا
منتصف شهر ايار مايو اقر حاكم بالجراد
فيات
بدخول ما سماها مجموعه تخريب واستطلاع
اوكرانيه الى اقليم جرايفورنسكي في
المقاطعه وبينما نفت كياف تورطها بالهجمات
اعلنت مجموعه تطلق على نفسها اسم الفيلق
الروسي الحر واخرى باسم فيلق المتطوعين
الروسي تنفيذ التوغل الذي لم يقتصر على
بالجراد بل وصلت المجموعه الى مقاطعه
كورسك المجاوره لكن موسكو ترفض الاعتراف
بوجود هاتين المجموعتين
تطورات فرضت سؤالا هل انتقلت المعركه الى
داخل روسيا سؤال ملح لا سيما مع حديث
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين عن ان ما
يجري محاوله لزعزعه الوضع داخل روسيا
ومخاطبا مجلس الامن القومي الروسي بالقول
يجب ان نفعل ما بوسعنا لمنعهم تحت اي ظرف
اما رئيس قوات فاجنر يفغيني فيصف الوضع في
بنكراد بالفوضى التي قد تحطم تدخل قواته
التي تعرف بالمرتزقه في القريب العاجل
لحمايه السكان ان لم تقم وزاره الدفاع
بذلك ليبقى التساؤل الابرز اين تموضعت
القوات الروسيه التي انسحبت من خاركيف
وسومي في اب اغسطس الماضي وما هو سبب عدم
نشرها في المقاطعات الحدوديه لاسيما
بالجراد وكورسك وبريونس
وفي ضخمه كذا قائد القوات البريه
الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه تتكبد خسائر كبيره على
جبهه بخموت بشكل يومي واشار سيسكي على
صفحته في تيليجرام بعد زيارته جبهه ضخمه
الشرقيه البلاد الى مواصله العمل مع جنوده
على الخطوط الاماميه والتخطيط لمزيد من
الاجراءات مع قاده الوحدات على الارض
وتعليقا على امكانيه عقد قمه سلام بشان
اوكرانيا في باريس قال الكريم ان فرنسا
ليست دوله محايده ولا يمكنها ان تكون
وسيطه في تسويه الصراع كونها تشارك فيه
الى جانب اوكرانيا واكد الكرملين ان
الرئيس الروسي فلادي ولا يزال منفتحا على
ايه صلاه لتحقيق اهداف روسيا بالطرق
الاخرى وليس بواسطه العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه واضاف الكرملين ان الغرب الجماعي
لم يترك لروسيا خيارات اخرى وفق تعبيره
وكانت
نقلت عن دبلوماسيين اوروبيين قولهم ان
حلفاء اوكرانيا يخططون لعقد قمه عالميه
بدون روسيا وذلك بهدف حشد الدعم وتاييد
شروط كييف لانهاء الحرب
وحسب الصحيفه فان القاده الاوروبيين
يضغطون من اجل مشاركه الدول التي حازت الى
جانب روسيا واتخذت موقفا محايدا وقد عبر
دبلوماسيون عن املهم في عقد القمه التي
سيدعى لها بايدن وقاده حلف النيتو قبل وقت
قصير من القمه في يوليو المقبل
ومعنا الان من موسكو
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه السابق من
برلين معنى اولرج بروكنر استاذ العلوم
السياسيه في جامعه ستانفورد في برلين اهلا
وسهلا بكما وابدا معك سيد
فدري فيدروف كيف تنظر روسيا لعقد هذه
القمه بدونها وخصوصا ان
الموقف الرسمي عن الدول الاخرى الدول التي
تعقد هذه القمه لم يصدر ما نعرفه فقط هو
ما جاء في هذه الصحيفه صحيفه
فما الذي ارادته روسيا
استباقيا من خلال التعليق عليها اليوم
هناك نظره سلبيه واضحه ازاء هذه القمه
المسمعي عقدها والتي قد تعقد في باريس
والسبب هو ان روسيا كما نرى لم تتم لن
توجه لها الدعوه ولكن ما هو الامر المهم
هنا انه لا توجد ايه ارضيه من وجهه نظر
روسيا لاجراء مثل هذه المحادثات لان الغرب
ما زال متمسكا بموقفه الذي اعلن في قمه
مجموعه السبع بانه لا توجد خطه سلام عدا
عن مقترحات
لذا بالنسبه لموسكو هذا غير مقبول
هل يمكن الحديث عن الغرب ككتله واحده هنا
في موقفه من انهاء هذه الحرب
والرغبه في اسراع هذا الانهاء
القمه التي ستعقد هل ستشهد
خطه جديده نوع من التراجع او محاوله
الالتقاء في منتصف الطريق ام ستكتفي
بالادانه
وعدم خروج موقف حقيقي على الارض ما رايك
سيكون مضيعه للوقت اذا ما التقوا فقط فقط
للاداره بالطبع الغرب متحد في رؤيه هذا
النزاع على انه انتهاك كبير للقانون
الدولي من جانب روسيا روسيا غازت اوكرانيا
وهذا امر غير مقبول وهذا الموقف تم تكراره
عده مرات ولا يحتاج الى قمه قمه من هذا
النوع تعتبر مهمه للبحث وبعض الحلول
الممكنه او
المواقف التي يتخذها كل الطرف رغم ان
الغرب واقف وقفه صامده دعما لاوكرانيا
هناك اختلافات في الرؤى حول ما يمكن ان
يتم عمله والى اي مدى يمكن ان يذهبوا
وماذا يمكن ان يفعل اساءه قبول لاوكرانيا
في صفوف النيتو وعضويه الاتحاد الاوروبي
واسئله اخرى
من يمكن ان يكون وسيطا نزيها في هذا
النزاع بالضبط ما كنت اسالك عنه سيد بركنر
الى اي حد فعلا هذا الاختلاف في المواقف
داخل صف الحلفاء يمكن ان ينتج عنه خطه
حقيقيه ونوع من الحل الذي يمكن ان يعرض
على روسيا في المقابل برايك
طريق الوحيده لانهاء هذه الحرب هو عن طريق
حل دبلوماسي ولن يكون هناك حل عسكري طبعا
مهم ان ما يحدث عسكريا في ساحه المعركه
لكن الحل في النهايه لابد وان يكون حلا
دوليا يشترك فيه الجميع والكل يعبر عن
مواقفه وفي النهايه تكون هناك ضمانات
امنيه لكلا الطرفين
المشتركين في هذا النزاع لذا هذا امر
يحتاج الى الكثير من التحضيرات
الدبلوماسيه وهذه القمه قد تكون بمثابه
قمه تحضير لكنها قد لا تكون حلا ربما تكون
اقترابا من البحث عن حل الدبلوماسي والاخ
بعين الاعتبار ما يدور في ارض المعركه
هل ترى ان موسكو مستعده في هذه المرحله
لتقديم شيء التنازل بمعنى الشروط التي
وصفت بانها تعجيزيه من المعسكر الاخر هل
هناك استعداد لمراجعتها
[موسيقى]
تبدو مطاطه سيد فادروف في هذا الاطار مع
تمسك كل الطرف بموقفه وبشروطه ما الذي
يمكن ان يحدث يعني ليكون هناك فعلا خرق
حقيقي
المشكله الاكبر هي ان روسيا تحتاج الى
ضمانات مرئيه واضحه ومضمونه لامنها
واحد المشكلات الاساسيه بالنسبه لروسيا
تكمن في ان اوكرانيا لن تكون اوكرانيا
عضوا في حلف الناتو اوكرانيا من وجهه نظر
روسيا يجب ان تبقى بلدا محايدا كيف ترى
انت السيد
الشروط التي يمكن ان يتم التراجع عنها
سواء من الطرف الاوروبي امن الطرف الروسي
من اجل التوصل الى خرق هنا
لو ان الامر يتعلق فقط
بالعضويه في منظمه امنيه اعتقد ان
اوكرانيا ممكن ان تغير الدستورها وتقدم
تنازلات
لكن الوضع في ميدان المعركه كما هو عليه
الان لا توجد فرصه لاوكرانيا بان تنضم الى
النيتو وهذا ما اوضحه الرئيس زنسكي طالما
ان النزاع العسكري مستمر لا يمكن لاي بلد
ان ينضم الى الاتحاد الاوروبي او الى حلف
الناتو لذا لو كان لدينا ضمانات امنيه ذات
مصداقيه ليس فقط لروسيا بل لاوكرانيا ايضا
في راي هذا سيكون الطريق الوحيد لانهاء
هذا النزاع
استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه ستانفورد
في برلين شكرا جزيلا لك
وشكراف نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه السابق
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]
سيكون لنا حديث معمق وموسع حول المجموعات
التي تنفذ هجمات داخل روسيا تحديدا ما
تعرف بمجموعه فيلق حريه روسيا
[موسيقى]
استمرت المعارك هو العنيفه بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع قبل ساعات من
انتهاء اخر الهدن المبرمه بين الطرفين
وجرت مواجهات غربيه العاصمه وجنوبها تسببت
في توقف تقديم الخدمات في مستشفى سوبا وهو
من اكبر المستشفيات الحكوميه المتخصصه في
البلاد وفي دار فور اطلقت نقابه الاطباء
نداء استغاثه بفعل هذه الاشتباكات واكدت
النقابه انهيار منظومه الخدمات الاساسيه
في الجنينه وحذرت من ان الاف الجرحى في
دارفور لا يتلقون العلاج اللازم وقد توفي
بعضهم
دخل القتال بين الجيش السوداني وقوات
الدعم السريع اسبوعه الثامن دون اي مؤشرات
لوقفه لا في الخرطوم ولا في ولايه دارفور
حسب مراسل الجزيره دوت اصوات الاسلحه
الثقيله حول مناطق واحياء غربي الخرطوم
واندلعت اشتباكات في جنوب ام درمان بينما
شهدت الاجواء تحليق طائرات عسكريه وتوقف
العمل بمعظم اقسام مستشفى سوبا وهو واحد
من اكبر المستشفيات الحكوميه المتخصصه في
البلاد في الاثناء حذرت نقابه اطباء غرب
دارفور من ان الماسي الانسانيه والامنيه
التي تضرب ولايتي الغرب ووسط دارفور هي
الاشد والاصعب منذ بدايه الحرب قائله ان
جميع خدمات الصحه والمياه والكهرباء
والاتصالات قد انهارت تماما في مدينه
الجنينه وان المنظمات الانسانيه غادرت
المدينه وانتشر فيها القناصه وعصابات
النهب يتعرض المدنيون داخل المدن او
الفارون منها للنهب والقتل
الواضح ان الهدنه الاخيره لاحقت بسابقاتها
من الهدن الفاشله التي توالت منذ السادس
من مايو الماضي برعايه امريكيه سعوديه ولم
تؤدي اغراضها الانسانيه ولم تفلح في حمايه
المدنيين
علقت واشنطن والرياض محادثات الطرفين قبل
انتهاء ايام الهدنه لفشلها في وقف
الاشتباكات وكان الجيش السوداني قد علق
اصلا مشاركته فيها بسبب ما وصفه بعدم
التزام قوات الدعم السريع ببنودها
والانسحاب بمنازل المواطنين والمستشفيات
التي تحتلها
المعروف ان واشنطن فرضت عقوبات على شركات
تابعه للجيش وقوات الدعم السريع وقيودا
على التاشيرات ضد جهات وصفتها بانها تكرس
العنف الراهن وهددت بمزيد من الاجراءات
اذا استمر قتال الطرفين
الثابت اذا ان مسار جد التفاوضي قد تعثر
الامر الذي يطرح بالحاح كل الاسئله عن شكل
وكنه المسار الجديد الذي يمكن اتباعه وكيف
سيكون دور مجلس الامن الدولي الذي مدد
مهمه بعثه يونيبت في السودان سته اشهر
اخرى وكان المجلس قد دان بشده في جلسته
الاخيره الهجمات على السكان المدنيين
وموظف الامم المتحده والعاملين في المجال
الانساني بالسودان وشدد على ضروره ضمان
الطرفين وصول المساعدات الانسانيه بسرعه
وامان
[موسيقى]
والان الى تركيا حيث اعلن الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان قبل قليل تشكيلته الحكوميه
الجديده والتي تميزت بتغيير معظم الوزراء
باستثناء وزيري الصحه فخر الدين خوجه
والثقافه والسياحه محمد نوري ارسوي من
ابرز المعينين جوده يلمس نائبا لرئيس
الجمهوريه وهاكان في دان وزيرا للخارجيه
وكان يشغل منصب مدير المخابرات وعلي
برلكايا وزيرا للداخليه وكان يشغل منصب
واليسطنبول اضافه الى محمد شمشك وزيرا
للخزانه والماليه كما ضمت التشكيله
الحكوميه وزيرا جديدا للدفاع هو يشار جولر
بدلا من خلص اكر
هذا وكان الرئيس التركي قد قال ان زمن
الحكومات الائتلافيه قد ولى واضاف خلال
كلمته في انقره في حفل تنصيبه رئيسا انه
سيسعى لتعزيز ديمقراطيه بلاده بدستور حر
ومدني وشامل واصفا الدستوره الحالي بانه
كان ثمره لنظام انقلابي
سنعزز ديمقراطيه بلادنا بدستور حر ومدني
وشامل عبر التحرر والخلاص من الدستور
الحالي الذي كان ثمره انقلاب عسكري فنتائج
الانتخابات الاخيره اظهرت تمسك ابناء
الشعب بالنظام الرئاسي الجديد كما اظهرت
هذه النتائج رفض ابناء شعبي للتركيا
القديمه ورفضهم لتركيا التي كانت تقاد عبر
الائتلافات الحكوميه لذلك يمكننا القول ان
زمن الالتلافات السياسيه في البلاد قد دول
هذا ودع الرئيس التركي المعارضه للتصالح
مع الاراده الوطنيه الناتجه عن الانتخابات
والتصرف بمسؤوليه لمصلحه الديمقراطيه
التركيه بحسب تعبيره واكد اردوغان ان
بلاده ستستمر في ممارسه دورها الفعال في
المنطقه والعالم وستقف الى جانب الشعوب
المظلومه
انتظروا من المعارضه التركيه ان تتصرف
بوعي ومسؤوليه وان تتصالح مع الاداره
الوطنيه لان هذا يصب في مصلحه وسلامه
ديمقراطيه بلادنا كما نؤكد اننا مصممون
على تطبيق مبدا مصطفى كمال اتاتورك سلام
في الوطن سلام في العالم عبر تعزيز مجال
نفوذ الدبلوماسيه الانسانيه كما سنستمر في
ممارسه دورنا الفعال في المنطقه والعالم
وسنقف الى جانب الشعوب المظلومه
ومن انقره ينضم الينا الان بالجيهان اذكر
البحث والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك اذا
رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان اعلن تشكيلته
الجديده ما الذي استوقفك في هذه التشكيله
كان هذا امر متوقعا منذ فتره طويله حين
يكون هناك انتصار انتخابي دائما هناك توقع
شامل من الشعب وكذلك من مؤسسه الدوله ان
يحصل تغيير
في كوادري الحكومه
والوزراء الذين استلموا حقائب وزاريه منذ
الحكومه السابقه كلهم
عينوا نوابا في الانتخابات السابقه
وبالتالي كان طبيعيا ان نجد او ان نرى
حكومه
جديده هناك شخصان فقط في هذه
الوزاره او الحكومه حافظ على
حقيبتيهما وزير الثقافه ووزير الصحه ولكن
كل من تبقى قد تغير هل هناك خيط ناظم في
الاسماء اذا سمحت خيط ناظم في الاسماء
الجديده التي حضرت في الاسماء الان
الموجوده حاليا
طبعا اذا هناك عدد من الاسماء المتميزه
مثل محمد
شمشك الذي عين في وزاره الخزانه والماليه
حيث انه معروف في السوق ومحبوب لانه لفتره
طويله كان الرئيس يعتمد سياسه ماليه غير
تقليديه مع تدني اسعار الفائده والتركيز
اكثر على الصادرات ولكن الان مع عوده شمشك
واضح ان الحكومه التركيه سوف تعود الى
السياسات التقليديه مثل ارتفاع اسعار
الفائده وغيرها من الاجراءات ايضا بالنسبه
لوزير الخارجيه
الذي كان لاكثر من عقدا رئيسه جهاز
المخابرات التركي طبعا ربما الجمهور لا
الكثير عنه ولكن خلف الكواليس
لطالما كان
مطلعا على كافه القضايا المرتبطه بسياسه
الخارجيه كان عضوا في دائره مقربه جدا
ومحصوره جدا مقربه من اردوغان كانت تتخذ
القرارات بالنسبه للقضايا الاستراتيجيه
والحساسه لفتره طويله
والانها كان في دان ينتقل من العمل خلف
الكواليس الى منصبان علني وهو
ياتي بخبرته وطول باعه في القضايا الامنيه
والاستراتيجيه وسياسيه الى هذا المنصب
الجديد كوزير خارجيه بالتالي ليس غريبا عن
قضايا شؤون الخارجيه
وليس غريبا عن نظرائه نبا كان فردا اساسيا
يعني تتوقع ان هناك عوده اذا سمحت لي في
موضوع الاقتصاد عوده
للسياسه التقليديه بسبب شخصيه وزير
الماليه الجديد ولكن فيما يتعلق بوزير
الخارجيه الذي كما قلت كانت ضمن دائره
اردوغان ويعمل خلف الكواليس اصلا هل نتوقع
اي تغيير في السياسه الخارجيه قريبا
بالنسبه لتركيا
اعتقد انه لفتره طويله قضايا شؤون خارجيه
التركيه كانت مرتبطه بالقضايا الامنيه ولا
هروب من ذلك لقد شاهدنا على سبيل المثال
وزيرا للدفاع الوطني ينشط
في السياسه الخارجيه ايضا هل كان فيدان
كان او كون فيدان هو وزير الخارجيه الان
فهذا مؤشر الى ان السياسه الخارجيه
التركيه
التي كانت مرتبطه بالامن والقضاء
الاستراتيجيه سوف تستمر كذلك لانه لفتره
طويله تركيا الى استخدام القوه العسكريه
من اجل ضمان مصالحها الوطنيه والقوميه
كاداه من ادوات السياسه الخارجيه انا ارى
انه في العقبه الجديده هذا الترابط سوف
يستمر لان كل القضايا الخليجيه الحساسه
والمهمه هي ايضا اميه وسياسيه مثل سوريا
جنوب القوقاز
اوكرانيا كلها قضايا مهمه
لتركيا وهي مرتبطه بالامن اشكرك شكرا
جزيلا لك
الباحث والمحلل السياسيين
[موسيقى]
قال رئيس الوزراء وزراء
ان من يقف خلف الاضطرابات شماليه البلاد
هي ميليشيات فاشيه عنيفه مرتبطه
وفق تعبيره واضاف ان الغرب يسترضي صربيا
لابعادها عن روسيا وان بلاده يجب الا تدفع
ثمن ذلك ومن جانبه قال الرئيس الصربي
الكسندر
انه ليس من مصلحتي بلاده مواجهه النيتو
وانها لا تريد الا مساعده الاغلبيه
الصربيه في شمال كوسوفو
احتقان متواصل في شمال كوسوفو بعد
انتخابات بلديه شهدت تراجع عن قياسيا في
المشاركه تلاه تصاعد في الجدل واعمال
العنف المحتجون الاصول الصربيه يرفضون
تمكين رؤساء البلديات الجدد من مهام عملهم
ويحاصرون مقر البلديات منذ اكثر من اسبوع
ضغطا باتجاه اعاده الانتخابات التي تتهمهم
حكومه كوسوفو بمقاطعتها في مناطقهم ما ادى
لضاله نسب المشاركه وتتهم كوسوفو حكومه
صربيا بتغذيه التوتر ووصف رئيس الوزراء
الكوسوفي في حديث للجزيره الرئيس الصربي
بالمستبد مؤكدا الوقوف في وجهه بحزم
اعتقد ان لا يجب ان نقف معا وبحزم في وجه
المستبدين من امثال رئيس الجاره الشماليه
لكوسوفو صربيا بدلا من محاوله استرضناهم
اكد كرتي للجزيره عدم سحب قوات شرطه
قبل مغادره من وصفها بالمليشيات الفاشيه
العنيفه لكنه سبق وابدى بعض المرونه قبل
يومين حين لوح على تويتر مساء الخميس
باجراء انتخابات جديده في تلك البلديات
الشماليه يتخوف رئيس الوزراء الكوسوفي كما
بدا في تصريحاته للجزيره من تخاذل واشنطن
والغرب عن دعمه سعيا لاجتذاب صربيا بعيدا
عن التحالف مع روسيا وحذر في هذا الاطار
من دفع بلاده ما اعتبره ثمنا لدى مقرطه
صربيا وصربيا في الوقت نفسه تشهد مظاهرات
حاشده في ميلجراد العاصمه ترفع العلم
الروسي وتعلن دعم الصرب شمال كوسوفو
ويتحدث الرئيس صربي لكزاندر فوتشيتش
معتبرا من عدم المصلحه الدخول في مواجهه
مع حلف الناتو داعيا في نفس الوقت لدعم
صرب كوسوفو ومرجحا اتضح الامور بعد زياره
المبعوثين الامريكي الاوروبي الى كوسوفو
صربيا خطوره التوتر في شمال كوسوفو لا
تنبع فقط من استحضار حرب عام 98 وتسعين من
القرن الماضي والتي قضى فيها اكثر من عشره
الاف انسان وشرد مليون اخرون لكن ايضا
لحساسيتها كنقطه احتكاك غربيه قد تفرضها
لاستقطابات مع احد حلفاء موسكو
[موسيقى]
وبالعوده الى التطورات الهجمات المتزايده
داخل روسيا قالت مجموعه ما يعرف بفيلق
حريه روسيا التي تتالف من روس يقاتلون مع
القوات الاوكرانيه قالت انها تقاتل قوات
الرئيس بوتين عند مشارف قريه تقع داخل
الحدود الغربيه لروسيا وذلك بعد يوم فقط
من اعلان موسكو صد الثلاث هجمات على
الحدود هذه الهجمات جاءت في اعقاب توغل
كبير في منطقه
بلغاريتا غربي روسيا يومي الثاني والعشرين
والثالث والعشرين من شهر مايو وزياده
القصف عبر الحدود في الاسابيع القليله
الماضيه
فيلق حريه روسيا يهدف الى انشاء منطقه
منزوعه السلاح على طول الحدود الروسيه
الاوكرانيه وذلك لمنع المدفعيه الروسيه من
اطلاق النار على اوكرانيا من الاراضي
الروسيه كما
هذا الفيلق قاتل الى الجانب القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه وذلك في مدينه
شرقي اوكرانيا وتفيد مصادر يقاتل بعض من
افراده في بخمت
وينظر اليهم على انهم جزء من المتطوعين
الدوليين الاوسع في القوات الاوكرانيه
طبعا لا تتوفر معلومات دقيقه ومن جهه
مستقله عن فيلق حريه روسيا الذي يقاتل الى
جانب القوات الاوكرانيه ضد سلطات موسكو
وما هو متاح مصدره اما الدعايه الخاصه
بالفيلق او المخابرات الاوكرانيه ويبقى
عددهم سريا للغايه ولا يمكن الوصول الى
موقعهم لنرى ماذا نعرف استنادا للمعلومات
المتداوله يتكون الفيلق من مجموعه شبه
عسكريه روسيه لكنها تتخذ من اوكرانيا مقرا
لها تعارض حكومه الرئيس فلاديمير بوتين
كذلك
تشكل هذا الفيلق في مارس 2022 ويقال انه
جزء من الفيلق الدولي للدفاع الاقليمي عن
اوكرانيا شعاره
يتمثل او يمثل بالاحرى قبضه تحمل
عبارتين روسيا وحريه ويستخدم العلم الابيض
والازرق والابيض الذي يراه جزء من
المعارضه الروسيه على انه علم روسيا الحره
يتالف هذا الفيلق فيلق حريه روسيا من
منشقين عن القوات الروسيه باضافه الى
متطوعين روس اخرين هجر بعضهم الى اوكرانيا
عقب نشوب الحرب
خلال مقابله في يناير الماضي قلل المتحدث
باسم المنظمه الذي يطلق على نفسه اسم قيصر
قال ان الفيلق يضم مئات المتطوعين الروس
وقد اشارت تقارير اعلاميه الى خضوع
المقاتلين في الفيلق لمقابلات واختبارات
نفسيه وحتى لجهاز كشف الكذب تحسبا لاي
محاوله اختراق
لمناقشه حجم وتاثير هذا الفيلق معنى من
لندن
وهو كبير محللي برنامج روسيا واوراسيا في
المعهد الملكي للشؤون الدوليه
ومؤلف كتاب الحرب الروسيه على الجميع اهلا
وسهلا بك سيد جاز اذا نحاول ان نفهم حجم
الازعاج الذي يشكلها هذا الفيلق الجديد
والذي نعرفه القليل ولكن من ضمن ما نعرف
انه يضم المئات ما حجم الازعاج
الذي يشكله لروسيا
صحيح
لروسيا
يبدو انها اكبر بكثير من الاعداد القليله
التي يضمها هي وحدات صغيره لكنها تسبب
فوضى على الحدود الروسيه لانها فضحت ان
هذه الحدود لا يتم الدفاع عنها وهي تنتقل
الى مناطق مختلفه على الحدود وتشير الى ان
سيطره روسيا عليها محدوده طبعا هذا يدفع
روسيا الى ان تاتي بتعزيزات من
اصدقائه وهذا طبعا سوف يساعد اوكرانيا حين
تبدا الهجوم المضاد سيكون هذا فعلا لان
روسيا عليها الان ان تحمي هذه الحدود
لانها مهدده باي توغلات نعم ولكن السؤال
يبقى يعني هل هي مجرد لساعات مزعجه ام
ممكن فعلا ان يصل الحد بها الى الضربه
مؤلمه لهذه الدوله النوويه التي تعتد
بنفسها
الى حجمها يجب ان تكون اللسعات صغيره ولكن
يبدو ان تاثيرها اكبر من واقعه هي اثبتت
ان روسيا ليست بالقوه التي تدعيها كانها
عاجزه عن حمايه مواطنيها على حدودها هذه
المجموعه الصغيره التي تاتي تسبب هلعا بين
السلطات المحليه اذا مره اخرى هذا يعزز
نقطه نقطه حول اوكرانيا اثباتها مفردها ان
روسيا ليست قوه لا يمكن
هزمها بل هي قوه هشه من السهل الانتصارات
ولكن الا يعزز ايضا نقطه اخرى من جانب
روسيا بان هذه القوات الصغيره كما وصفت لا
يمكن ان تحدث كل هذا الضرر اذا لم تكن
مدعومه اوكرانيا وغربيا ومن ثم الشرط الذي
كان قد وضع من اجل تسليم هذه الاسلحه
لاوكرانيا بالاسلحه الغربيه في الواقع
يوظف لضرب الاراضي الروسيه ومن ثم هناك رد
فعل قاسي وقوي قد يحدث قريبا
دائما روسيا تريد ان تقنع الاخرين ان هناك
رد فعل قوي وصارم في اي لحظه ان تهديد
التصعيد الروسي سمعينه منذ بدايه هذا
الصراع وكان فعالا في تقييد ما قدمته دول
الغير التي المانيا الولايات المتحده الى
اوكرانيا ولكن طبعا كل هذه التهديدات قد
اثبتت فراغها ولكن الولايات المتحده فعل
القناه انها لا تريد ان توفر اسلحه تستخدم
في ضربات ضد روسيا اوكرانيا تشير الى ان
هذه منظمه او مجموعه قريبه
من القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه وطبعا بهذا
الطريقه هي
تحاول ان ترسي توازنا هشان الولايات
المتحده عربات عن عدم موافقتي على ذلك
ولكن بالنظر الى تاثير ذلك على الصراع
عامه قد يمر ذلك وربما سوف لن نسمع اعتراض
من ادوار الغربيه فالمملكه المتحده مثلا
تدعم اذا ان تكون روسيا تعاني نتيجه
افعالها نعم ولكن هناك نقطه اخرى تقول
انها في النهايه روسيا خوفت العالم وحذرت
من التصعيد ولكن كان هذا التخويف اجوف
فارغ من المضمون ولكن اليس صحيحا ايضا ان
هناك ورقه لم تستخدمها موسكو حتى الان
وربما هذا الاستمرار في الاستفزاز والذي
ياتي من جانب هذه المجموعات
قد يدفعها لاستخدام السلاح النووي
التكتيكي الذي يخشاه الجميع
ان روسيا
او يخشى واقع ان روسيا قد تستخدم
الاسماويه لانها روجت لذلك ضمن حمله واسعه
ولكن بمجرد انه ليس هناك وضع فعل فعلي
يحسن
موقف عروس اذا استخدمت الاسلحه النوويه
فهذا تعتبر قصه تخويف ولكن هذا التهديدات
لم تحصل في الاشهر الاخيره لان روسيا رددت
هذه التكرادات كل مره
اشكرك وصلت الفكره اشكرك
اذا كنت معنا من لندن شكرا
قال بيان لحركه حماس في فلسطين نوفدا من
قاده الحركه برئاسه اسماعيل هنيه رئيس
المكتب السياسي وصل القاهره بدعوه مصريه
ويضم خالد مشعل وصالح العروري وخليل الحيه
وروحي مشتهى ومن المقرر ان يلتقي الوفد
المسؤولين المصريين لبحث العديد من
القضايا السياسيه والميدانيه وفق البيان
اعلن رئيس التيار الوطني الحر في لبنان
جبراننا باسيل حصوله ما سماه التقاطع مع
كتل نيابيه اخرى على اسم الوزير السابق
جهاد زعور من بين اسماء اخرى وصفها بانها
غير مستفزه وذلك لتولي رئاسه الجمهوريه
ووصف باسيل في كلمه له هذا التقاطع بانه
تطورا ايجابي
صار معروف انه نحن
تقاطعنا مع كتل نيابيه اخرى على اسم جهاد
ازعور من بين اسماء اخرى من بين اسماء
اخرى اعتبرناها مناسبه غير مستفزه ونحن
اعطينا موافقتنا عليها او عدم ممانعتنا
لوصوله وهن اختاروا واحد منهم ونحنا راينا
انه يصير التقاطع على اكثر من اسم
لنفجع اكثر مرونه
الى تونس حيث اذاعه جبهه الخلاص الوطني
الى اطراق اطلاق سراحي قاده الجبهه وغيرهم
من السياسيين المعتقلين وفي وقفه تضامنيه
مع المعتقلين السياسيين في العاصمه طالب
المشاركون بالتوقف عن ملاحقه نشطاء على
خلفيه مواقفهم السياسيه واسقاط ما وصفوه
بالانقلاب وعوده الديمقراطيه كما شدد
المشاركون على اهميه التصدي لما وصفوه
بالتفرد بالسلطه
لهذا ينتهي الحصاد هذه الليله شكرا جزيلا
على المتابعه
[موسيقى]